hey you guys it's movie a retrospective
time once again now this movie right
here this is another one that has been
on my list since whenever the hell we
even started doing movie retrospectives
and I made like my first like master
list of all the movies that I wanted to
do like only 10% of which I've got to
but this one has been on there since the
very beginning because I [ __ ] love
this movie and I feel like I mean I
guess if you're people they're really
really into Italian horror and like the
school of Dario Argento and stuff they
might have seen it but I feel like this
really isn't one that gets a lot of
mainstream attention and it really
should because it's a really cool weird
zombie movie it's good-looking movie
it's very very Italian it is very tiny
but not it it's it's weird it's a weird
it's a weird movie um but not but in a
good way yeah I got a hot girl in it
this chick she's just sucking when you
see her she's like he's supernatural
yeah yeah she's like a supermodel and
she's stacked though you know and
there's a weird story she keeps coming
back he's seeing her over and over again
and she's a different person each time
and she [ __ ] this dude over he works in
a cemetery and she [ __ ] him over
mentally and like physically every or
sexually every time she sees him you
don't know what's real it's [ __ ] and
that's a good thing it's the weird thing
about these old attend this is a retro
style Italian [ __ ] it's from 1994 from
94 but the way it's added in the way his
story's tone is told it kind of feels
like it's from 74 visually it looks
stunning though I liked it it's a
beautiful like very gothic yen movie I
enjoyed the movie I didn't really
understand it just I'd have to see it a
couple times yeah it's one of those ones
that and okay so the interesting thing
about this one and you really don't see
a lot of movies like this it has
elements of um you know splatter zombie
movies like you know made brain-dead of
you know a dead alive Evil Dead it has
some stuff like that but but then it has
like some terry gilliam s kind of stuff
like be referring to brazil yeah and
then it has like
some kind of arty philosophical
existential kind of stuff never mind
like Rosencrantz and Guildenstern are
dead or something like that where it has
that - but it's not so arty a movie that
it's like an art film and everyone will
roll their eyes it's still like a fun
weird it Cory
maybe reminded me of a little bit more
of Rome Roman Polanski film kind of like
the tenant it was kind of like that you
know sort of but funny funny because I
cobbled it immensely yeah tone is more
like Evil Dead but it was doing [ __ ]
like the tenant did where reality was
getting warped you weren't sure what was
real and it was a lot yeah and there was
a lot of this [ __ ] have mirroring or
peel like in different identities like a
David Lynch movie like Lost Highway or
Mulholland Drive yeah it had a little
bit of that going on but like I said
it's not like so arty-farty that ever
that people like roll their eyes and
it's still like a fun yes zombie movie
yeah like in the way Evil Dead is fun in
the way that Evil Dead is fun it has
like some fun gore and it's it's
essentially I would call it a surrealist
existential horror comedy because I
think it is a comedy first and foremost
although it has a lot of horror elements
to it but you can just watch it
straightforward like that you know just
for the zombies just for the weirdness
and just right and the boobs and it has
a lot of action in it - which that
wasn't in or Polanski film yeah but it
is it's weird you know I mean it's it's
just you gotta take the movie on it you
know you you can't make this movie
something that it isn't you just have to
kind of take it as it comes it's
visually stunning it's a beautiful
beautiful look at maybe it's got its
it's basically a love story between this
guy and this super hot [ __ ] chick and
she's weird as [ __ ] and she's different
and I guess she dies and keeps coming
back it's hard to tell cousin some you
just have to see it for yourself isn't
ya the same woman it's the same actress
it's the same character but she keeps
coming back in a different form
different performances yeah like she
leaves but then she comes back and I
think even some versions of her die
right and she still gets back yeah yeah
so let's see a cemetery where you bury
the people and they come back to life
and
nobody believes him he works in the
cemetery and that's just not the only
thing there's a bunch of other weird
[ __ ] you can't tell what's real like I
said it's surrealistic but not in a way
that's necessarily gonna like piss
people off or they're gonna be super
confused because it's still fun to watch
I'm at and when that ending came man
like I said it there are a lot of
different interpretations it leaves it
open to interpretation but there's I've
heard a lot of like really good
interpretations and I don't know if
anyone is the right one of the wrong one
okay so let's go into a little context
about this now by the time that this was
made in 1993 it actually came out in
1984 um Italian horror cinema and Dario
Argento was still making movies stuff
like that but they the heyday of the
Italian horror film had kind of passed
now this movie was famously directed by
miquellee suavi now he started out as an
actor he was in some early you know
Italian horror and then he for a time
worked with Dario Argento for I believe
at least 10 years for like on second
unit stuff he was an assistant director
stuff like that he worked on tenebrae he
worked in opera he worked on phenomena
so so him and Dario were kind of like
simpatico and then he's also later
worked with Terry Gilliam he worked on
The Adventures of Baron Munchausen he
also worked on Lamberton bhavas demons
movies so this guy is like very very
high up in the Italian film hierarchy
unfortunately he only made a few movies
he made the stage fright from which I
think came out in 1987 you know very
well known slasher he also made the
church which is kind of a mess but I
really liked it the sect which I saw a
long time ago but don't remember that
much about and then he made this one
della morte del amor a better known in
the u.s. in the UK as cemetery man even
though I do think that the original
title was better now where this came
from
okay so in 1986 this guy named tiziano
sclavi he started doing this comic book
series called Dylan dog now dylan dog is
about like a paranormal investigator now
I don't know if this series is still
ongoing because it's very was very very
long-lived it's kind of a cult comic and
u.s. but Italy it was massively popular
I mean you could buy it at any from what
I've heard you could buy it at any
newsstand just like you can buy [ __ ]
Archie comics and [ __ ] like that over
here they were everywhere like everybody
was really into this interestingly the
character of Dylan at you know the
paranormal investigator in this comic
book he drew it based on the English
actor Rupert Everett who if you've seen
cemetary man is the main character in
this movie so that did not happen like
on purpose necessarily he just thought
Rupert Everett looked cool like from
some of the other movies that he was in
and used him like as a model for the
Dylan dog character and it just so
happened that later on they're like hey
when we're making dellamorta dell amore
which was based on the novel of the same
name which tiziano sclavi wrote before
he did the comic book but he didn't
publish it until after the comic book
got popular you know what I mean so but
they were able to get Rupert Everett to
do this even though Rupert Everett kind
of more known for doing rom-coms or
period dramas or stuff like that he's
more of like a theatrical like
Shakespearean style actor so he didn't
really like horror movies and I don't
think he's done one sense which is kind
of a shame because he is really really
[ __ ] good in this I think the cool
thing about him he's a little bit like
you know ash and evil dead but it's not
not as zany he's very sardonic he's very
dry he's very so he works at this
Cemetery in Italy called buff Elora in
this little town and he's very world
weary so in this Cemetery like some
people not everybody but sometimes when
he buries people seven days after they
die they come back out of the graves as
zombies and he has gotten to the point
like at the beginning of this movie he's
gotten to the point where he's just so
over it that it's like you know the
zombies show up in his little cottage in
the middle of the cemetery and he's just
like talking on the phone and she's like
hey hang on a minute blam and then like
he just goes back to the phone call cuz
it's just like a very workaday thing to
happen yeah they're zombies but they can
talk from like remember weren't they
talking yeah and some of them still
maintained the immense identity
personality too
you have his arrows yeah baby ghost his
character who is kind of like there's
this whole one of the themes of the
movie I think is kind of like just the
repetition of life or how life just
becomes you know life and death almost
become like intertwined or they become
almost the same thing and that's kind of
one of the things that he says he's just
so like over it and he doesn't care and
he doesn't really like relating to
living people he's like much happier
being alone or being around dead people
because he doesn't really have to like
you know interact so he's so he's almost
kind of like at a point where he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the world and
he has a sidekick named Nagi and this
guy is played by a French actor Francois
[ __ ] Lazaro is I think how you pronounce
his name he's like a French rock star
actually he's learned and he's an opera
singer too I believe yeah this is a
great character and yeah he's really one
of the best and he was also in he was in
city of lost children which is also a
great movie he was in a couple other
like real weird movies like that kind of
looks like curly from the Damned yeah
bald little short fat guy and he and his
characters kind of he's like a mentally
[ __ ] guy yeah but that's his best
friend and [ __ ] it's a trip and he's
like yeah and he's like he can only say
like one where he can only say yeah
that's why they call him Nagi and um but
he's kind of like he's almost like a
puppy dog you know what I mean like he's
kind of like mentally challenged but
he's like really sympathetic and like
kind of sweet and cute and everything
and um he's a little boy yeah so
initially of francesco della morte who's
a Rupert Everett's character kind of
treats him like crap you know what I
mean but you know later on they kind of
like the whole friendship thing comes
about but so they're dealing with this
outbreak of zombies in Buffalo a
cemetery ya know he believes them and
nobody believes that and in a way to
this this is kind of where the terry
gilliam saying comes in where it's
almost kind of like this the only other
living friend that francesco has is this
other guy named Franco who works in this
like like a very Brazil style not Brazil
the country but Brazil the MU media um
you know very like with all the stacked
paperwork and all this like ridiculous
like pointless
you know bureaucracy and stuff you so
you have to fill out this exact form for
him to complain you know to get extra
money for dealing with the zombies and
all this other stuff and
you know he doesn't just doesn't want to
do it he's like you know what it's
easier to just shoot him and it's like
no one believes him anyway and then he
tells them they they just come back to
life and they people just blow it off
like yeah he's joking I have another
underlying theme of the thing to not
only just this whole workaday we're not
getting anywhere like Sisyphean kind of
like pushing the rock up and it falling
back down but it's just also kind of
like there's this layer of bureaucracy
where no one really gives a crap it's
like there's the mayor and it's like all
he cares about if you ever seen the
movie Brazil you'll know exactly what
we're talking about like was lifted
right from looks like yeah some of this
stuff is lifted right from them like I
said the director of this Micheli so
obby worked with Terry Gilliam Lena was
actually like a big fan of his so you
know so they call a pot and get the
Brazil yeah so so you can see where that
like influence came from and so you know
into this you know cauldron of weirdness
comes this beautiful mysterious woman
now this chick right here bright is this
should be illegal to anna falchi should
it should be illegal to be this pretty
that she's allah if that's what i mean
if like looks like the next step in
human evolution yes she's like
otherworldly a beautiful and she looks
like a supermodel but unlike an American
supermodel we're at empty flat she this
chick is stacked yeah and she just
affected outstanding Oh like yeah
genetics are just off the [ __ ] shark
and she's naked in this quite a bit
so you know if you're into that another
place the only thing is kind of only
woman that I've seen on the movies kind
of close to this it would be kind of
like the girl that played the vampire
girl from life
Matilda man yet that like that [ __ ] yeah
that's that's another that's a good
thing because here's the thing so this
woman turns up at a funeral for this old
guy who Francesco initially thinks is
her dad but actually turns out to have
been her husband he's like way way away
older than her and so Francesco is
immediately in love with this woman and
she's kind of like not really feeling it
you know and she's kind of regaling him
with tales of like what a wonderful
lover this old guy wasn't yet alike
EMI is like 70 like a glitch looking
face was it one of the best gags of this
is like because there's a little picture
if I'm on the gravestone yeah and it's
like every time somebody says something
over here like that he doesn't approve
of he'll either be smile on her frown
and like I'm a little different so
finally so Francesco is like trying to
get in her pants and everything because
he's falling in love with her like
immediately at first sight which you
know I can understand like if he harbors
it it would be so um so he she's just
kind of like yeah whatever I can't
really is my dead husband blah blah but
then with the second he says this
cemetery has a beautiful ossuary she's
like hmm and she is into that [ __ ] yeah
so that yes so there's like a whole
thing we're like you know there she goes
in there and she's getting all up in the
bones and it's all like gross and
everything and she's dead finish yeah
and they're all like [ __ ] on her
husband's grave because he you know
because I never kept secrets for a man
yet he would have wanted to know yeah
she kind of she kind of insinuated that
it was an open relationship he didn't
keep secrets that she didn't keep yeah
and then that kind of [ __ ] went down
that's how I interpreted it sorry I
guess it could be interpreted either way
you know what I mean it's it didn't
necessarily have to be but I how I kind
of yeah so so there's that whole thing
now what he was doing a lecherous face
on the photograph so yeah so so as much
as like he's into that and then like she
seems to fall for him too after like he
impresses her with with how awesome the
ossuary is and you know all this death
feather stuff and all that but then
tragedy occurs when there's a thing
where cuz when they're [ __ ] on the
dead husband's grave yeah this is
spoilers now yes boiler spoilers like
and oh okay so if you want to watch this
movie before we talk about it it's free
on YouTube like somebody has uploaded it
and it's good quality it's like HD which
is good because this is a [ __ ] to get
hold of I don't even think it's out on
blu-ray um there was a DVD I think
Anchor Bay didn't put out a DVD of it in
2006
which I think I have somewhere but I
think it might be in the attic so watch
it free on YouTube but it is enough
don't be like before somebody like takes
it down Rose I'm sure it's like a
copyright violation even though the the
thing about it is that you know this was
released on a grand total of six movie
theaters in the u.s. you know so
obviously it didn't do very well cuz
like I said black comedy is a very hard
sell and this is a weird movie this
isn't something that Hollywood would
have gotten behind you this is not yeah
I mean this is not not so weird that
it's off-putting but weird it's a weird
movie it doesn't fit the American market
it doesn't fit into one genre yeah and
it's not and Hollywood is not gonna bump
one of their movies out of the theater
put this in it yeah this is just to odd
this is too much of an oddball type of
movie so yes so various things intervene
so they're [ __ ] on the old dudes grave
and he zombified because I guess the
seven days underground underneath the
ground and what comes out and like
invites her yeah and then there's a
thing where you know Francesco thinks
she's dead from the bite or from a heart
attack or whatever and so he knows that
he's gonna have to shoot her when she
comes back as a returner they don't call
him zombies in this movie he calls them
returners and um then it comes to pass
that she actually wasn't dead so he
killed her when she was still alive and
she came back later as a zombie and then
as the movie goes on he starts like two
more times he meets another woman who
was a different woman but he's a man
played by that same actress right and
she seems to respond to him the same way
as the first woman that if she knew him
even though she's a different woman
yeah which that kind of [ __ ] throws
you is he imagining that all these women
are the same and they all look the same
is it the same one coming back in you
know in different bodies it's it's just
an unknown I think she's a figment of
his imagination I think she's a
representation tation of [ __ ] true
love so I think it's different women
that's like his idealized
he's seeing baby seeing it that's what I
thought it was too that is I mean you
could interpret it in different ways
because like I said the ending of this
is gonna make you think oh maybe the
whole things didn't happen or you know
there are various other things going on
but I do
that she's just a representation or
you're just seeing her through his eyes
and and that kind of that kind of keys
back to what you're telling I didn't
trust he was friends with the dude who
made the movie Brazil yeah because now
you throw that in the mix cuz there's a
lot of that kind of [ __ ] that goes on in
Brazil it's a representation of an
idealized [ __ ] mate as well yeah it
is yeah and which that's kind of like
something you'd see in Brazil yeah movie
Brazil right not trying to destroy
Brazil has nothing to do Brazil yeah
other than the damn horrible bureaucracy
which that Brazil is a horrible
bureaucracy yes so this does have a
little bit of that this it you know what
I mean so this is kind of like I said
it's it's like Evil Dead meets Terry
Gilliam meats super gothic Italian it's
not as much like a Dario Argento movie
as you might think
even though Micheli suave worked with
the Jerry origins who for a very long
time and was an Italian tone it has an
Italian toque but a lot of Italian
movies have that that it isn't as Dario
ask as you might think it actually makes
a lot more even though it doesn't sound
like it when we're talking about it it
actually makes a lot more narrative
sense than some Dario Argento boobies do
um well Italian theater especially we
talk about Dario Argento he said some of
these like you know horror stuff it's
more about Impressionism it's not about
yeah and narrative and [ __ ] they're
more body effect looks how it made you
feel and dreamlike and this one is kind
of dreamlike too but I don't know in a
different way but I guess Dario's are
Dario's are more like fairytale ask I
guess this one has a little bit of that
too but I don't know these movies are
also a lot of times just made in edit
yeah shoot all kinds of [ __ ] and they
just start adding things to editing
things together
does that look pretty did that flow
right yeah yeah let's just go with that
and it really might have not had
anything to do with really the way the
story was originally supposed to go yeah
yeah they just the aside Wells decide I
feel like they work a lot more from not
so much like thinking about it ahead of
time but they think of like you know
instinctively they're just going to
corner
it's not yeah it for the American
audience in general it doesn't work yeah
in general the American audience picks
stories apart and you know me is looking
for plot holes and [ __ ] narrative and
thematic [ __ ] [ __ ] and Vic and what'd
he call it
character development usually that's not
there you know not usually
although like I said I I can appreciate
I love Italian movies particularly
jell-o movies I love Dario J so he was
Italian horror stuff like that
but you have to go into it knowing that
it's a difference a cultural difference
between like oh no difference if the
best Italian movies I think ever was the
[ __ ] man no-name trilogy yeah which
is you know [ __ ] Fistful of Dollars
you know if like in few dollars more and
what was it yeah you know yeah yeah
those are really good yeah yeah so um so
they were more like an American
narrative is what I'm saying yeah yeah I
mean but the Dario is gentle stuff no it
isn't well like I said it's very
dreamlike with that but that was kind of
his thing this one like I said has a
little bit of that although it seems
more grounded even though it's more
surrealist if that makes any sense if
you've seen the movie you probably know
what I'm talking about so while this
whole thing is going on with francesco
della morte with you know these mystery
women turning up you also have the
delightful side story of Nagi
now Nagi who like I said he's a mentally
challenged but he's very East very sweet
this little pudgy dude and everything
like that and he's kind of like the
sidekick he has developed a crush on the
mayor's daughter Valentina who was just
a teenager now shortly after meeting her
she's also dumb as rocks she is yeah DOM
is rock pretty just dumb as rocks
shortly after meeting her he gets
nervous and throws up all over her yeah
um you know he forgets about her she's
just kind of like no big you know and I
mean so she goes for a motorcycle ride
with this guy that she likes named
Claudio you know he's all this with the
leather jacket very say Khomeini and hey
mr. pretty boys and gets on there and
she is pretty much immediately killed by
it they all hit a bus they become a
bustling Boy Scouts to go off a cliff
it's like all the butter psycho boobs
get run over and super gory it's very
funny
so when so after she gets killed and all
the bodies get buried at the Buffalo
cemetery so all of them start to come
back now Nagi is very excited because he
was in love with Valentina and now she's
dead and he knows that she's gonna come
back and maybe he'll have a shot with
her now and so he actually goes to her
grave with this little violin that he
made out of a little wooden coffin and
he's like playing her a song like
waiting for her to wake up and then like
when she wakes up he cut off her head
her every animated head and like takes
it back to his little basement with him
and puts her in a broken TV and like
singsong stare at stuff and she's into
it yeah it's like it's so [ __ ] funny
and it's like it's just this it's just
so so I mean it's horrific but it's also
like super cute so okay so you got that
going on too which is adorable but also
you have the whole [ __ ] with Francesco
now not only has he killed his first
dream woman um in a foul keys character
who actually has never given a name
she's only called she that's what they
call her right she they don't call her
she doesn't have a name
and even when she's introduced because I
think the second time were like when the
new mayor comes in she's the mayor's
secretary and he says this is my
secretary he doesn't say what her name
is or anything say never give her a name
so I think that's kind of significant
like I said it kind of points to the
idea that she's just like a
representation she's an archetype yeah
of his like perfect woman or whatever
and he's seeing every woman yeah every
time he meets one it's just not what she
it's not what he thinks it is yeah yeah
yeah so so in between that like he
starts getting there's just one really
cool scene one thing that he does um for
whatever we like he's really into
reading old phone books and it whenever
somebody dies and he buries them in the
cemetery he crosses their name out of
the phone directory so nagi like burns
one of the phone books one of his last
poems he gets really upset about it cuz
he's like I was it was a classic I
really thought with that yet you know
what I mean so but the pages start to
burn and the it's really cool because
all the burned pages come up and they
make like a big grim reaper and the grim
reaper starts talking to him and saying
basically hey stop killing the dead
who's really shooting the zombies the
returners or whatever and it's like you
know if you're gonna
pull [ __ ] like that I guess these death
is saying you're stepping on my dick
it's like why don't you just go out and
kill the living essentially so what
Francesco does because I didn't mention
this but earlier in town there's all
these kind of like you know bro type
dudes in town that make fun of him
because he's an outsider and also he's
like there's a thing that where he's
impotent or he doesn't have a dick or
something like that but he does he does
but don't think it but everybody just
thinks that and they don't really
explain like why everybody started
thinking that it's just like I said it's
this is a very symbolic or archetypal
type story so it's not like a
straightforward this really happened
because some of the stuff in this might
not have happened or it might all be
from his imagination or like I said it
might just be type of a fairy tale
archetypal type of story
so so he basically goes into town and
after death tells him this and just mows
down like a whole bunch of living people
now the funny thing about this is that
he can commit all these crimes like in
front of people and [ __ ] like that
and he doesn't get in trouble so it's
almost like he doesn't exist
you know what I mean because there's
another realities where reality isn't
real because it's almost kind of like
American Psycho in that way where he's
just going around doing all this crazy
[ __ ] and he's like running around
covered in blood and axes and everything
like that and nobody reports it or I
mean even when he goes around saying I
did it I murdered the people there's
like whatever we don't you to do that
yeah so it's kind of like that type of
thing to write because an American cycle
you end up not knowing whether or not
maybe he's just imagining right healing
these people right or maybe he is
getting away with it just because of his
[ __ ] social class yeah see it might
be that - I'd be that so like I said I
suspect that it's more like an American
Psycho thing where maybe this is not
really happening or it's all in his mind
or it's in someone else's mind or
something like that so so like I said so
he meets this other woman who looks just
like anna falchi again and in this
situation she seems to respond to him as
though she knows him and like falls in
love with him right away and stuff - but
the catch is that she is she's so glad
that she's heard that he's impotent yes
she has a dick phobia she does not like
being penetrated and so she's like I can
only love an impotent
so no Hakka phobia yes so even though
he's he's not really impotent he tells
her oh I'm totally a impotent and then
the next hilarya tries to go the doctor
gives him this injection that'll make
his dick [ __ ] guess so smaller you
like he doesn't even have wanted it for
a month erna like dead in it he's
unlucky because when he goes down there
to finally [ __ ] cook up whether she
goes oh I changed my mind
you know uh she's like I don't have a
dick phobia well no they well they have
sex first and it goes okay and then
which is very funny seeing cuz there's
like a sex scene and she's like oh
because he's like oh I might not be able
to do it cuz I don't think my medication
is working or something like that and
she's like oh I don't think the
medication is working or whatever but
what happens with this and this is like
completely not PC but I guess you could
get away with this in the 90s what ends
up happening is that she gets raped by
the mayor they don't show it but she
just like talks about she did she says
she did and then she's like because she
was gonna marry Francesco and so she
gets raped by the mayor and she was like
I liked it yeah it's like cuz oh well he
did it on the phone
nicely like you know to say he was sorry
she had sex with her again and she's
like you know so I so I'm over my phobia
so I can't marry you now I'm gonna marry
him you could get away with that in an
Italian movie you could italian so you
could probably do that today in italian
you probably could get crazy they are
crazy
that was just a kind of a plot device
though yeah because it was just going to
show him like I said I'd love to show
that she's [ __ ] crazy cuz she's crazy
and every [ __ ] yeah in every inner
way every iteration of her she's [ __ ]
well it's not so much crazy it's just
like I said I think that this is his
perception of her what's happened and I
think though the whole point of
Francesco's character the reason this is
called della morte dell amore not only
is his last name della morte his
mother's last name was dell amore which
means of love whereas della morte means
of death so he's kind of like and
because he works at this cemetery he's
kind of like on the cusp like between
life and death but he can't really
choose either thing like because he's
kind of indifferent and Micheli so avi
has come out and said this is not a
horror movie you
based on people's fear of death this is
a horror movie based on someone who is
afraid to live so he's talking about
this is a person who embraces death
because they fear it less than living
you know what I mean because he's just
like kind of locked himself away from
the world and he's perfectly happy
living in this little cottage by himself
not really having any friends are just
hanging out with dead people so I think
that the fact that he sees this woman as
his idealized mate and that when he
meets her again and again in every
iteration she ends up quote-unquote
[ __ ] him over or something ends up
going wrong is because it's like a
representation of his fear like it's
almost kind of like she's not gonna live
up to what I think she should be you
know what I mean I think that's kind of
where that's going with that because
what happens with when he meets her
again a third time he's like bummed out
at a pub or something like that and he
meets these three girls that need a ride
and one of them whose name I think she's
actually named I think she says her name
is Laura but um you know her again but
it's her again right and he goes back to
the thing and it turns out that she's
keep prostate thing she loves her but
turns out he's yeah because she's all
like oh that's what I wanted to get yeah
and this you know my my interpretation
of it based upon my experience isn't
[ __ ] knowing guys and you know dudes
like we know from the club who get
especially when they're young they get
wrapped up in these girls all right and
they get wrapped up and do all this kind
of stupid [ __ ] behind these girls
because they have in their mind a very
artificial image of who that woman is
yeah they're not in love with that woman
they're in love with who they're imagine
a woman could be yeah and not the way
they are yeah and that's what that's
what I am yeah that's kind of what I
said he's a young guy and he's meeting
different women but he's imagining them
to all be this idealized Verte well you
gonna get disappointed every time yeah
and that's eventually exactly what
happened yeah you gotta take a woman for
who she is now who you want her to be
yeah and that's what's going on yeah
there's definitely like a big thing of
that too um and I think that the fact
that I'm used to the third one that he
meets that ends up being cuz she's all
like oh I love you and this and that and
they have
it's great and everything like actually
I think she was the one that was talking
about the that was talking about the
medication and stuff yes I think that's
what I thought because I said that's how
I remembered yeah that's right I forgot
I know huh she he shows up to finally
[ __ ] kind of like make out with her
and get married to her and she goes oh
guess what I love you but I gotta go
with this dude who raped me yeah because
he does me oh that kid that was yeah he
got me over my macaca phobia yeah so
he's like he's like sitting there going
oh good thing I didn't cut my junk off
yeah because he would have cut his junk
off for nothing yeah you did a self
emasculation yeah that's I understood
that theme to that's how it is dude yeah
this is just the you know this is a
series of [ __ ] like I said before two
series of stories about women from a
young man's point of view he's bending
over backwards to [ __ ] satisfy a
woman that doesn't even exist it's a
woman he thinks exists yeah turns out no
you know one of them is screwing her
boss the other ones a [ __ ] hooker the
other ones you know this and they're all
different
yeah okay but none of them are who you
none of those none of those women are
who you think she is uh yeah but none of
them live up to their ideal is he's in
love with this image this internal image
he's infinity yeah you know and so they
see these young dudes [ __ ] doing
stupid [ __ ] behind women that do stupid
[ __ ] well you know sell them sold to
some woman you know well I feel like
she's a lesbian dude well like a lot of
make that can't make her laugh cuz I do
it you know exactly I'm talking about
that that girl's a lesbian man she don't
[ __ ] love you yeah you just love her
yeah well I think that happens a lot
with with guys it's it's kind of like
you know they kind of put a woman on a
pedestal like you said they have they've
constructed like a whole idea of this
woman in their head like a whole
relationship in their hands we met the
girl before they even know them or
before they know them all that well they
have a fantasy woman in their mind
they've built up and then they meet some
woman and put that [ __ ] fantasy honor
yeah and that was [ __ ] up to do that's
what they do not do that's a young guy
[ __ ] mistake
yeah your shadows please don't do
they're supposed to [ __ ] get over
that by the age of 17 I mean you would
think that some guys if they don't some
guys don't learn and some guys it's been
- because sometimes as you see in this
movie even though it's done like kind of
more humorously or dark humor in this
one is that when you are when you have
built up this woman to such an extent
and you are disappointed it makes you go
off the deep end because as soon as
Francesco finds out that the third woman
is a prostitute
like we know the roommate starts asking
for money and everything like that you
know and he says but she said she loved
me and is like oh that'll be more you
know it may be you all right you're
paying for that so he essentially he
burns down their apartment
yeah with a minute what's that minute so
he kills three random women yeah now the
thing that happens in this and this is
interesting too so after that happens um
he ends up like he almost kind of he
doesn't go turn himself in but he's not
trying to hide or nothing
so like the cop comes to his tent comes
to the cottage in the cemetery and then
you know he essentially says hey don't
you want to talk about those three girls
that died in the apartment in the fire
and stuff like that he's like oh we got
the guy that did that that guy also
killed his wife and daughter and it
turns out that it was his friend Franco
from the earlier from the office earlier
that lend the guy he's talked to him on
the phone a couple times too so Franco
is essentially taking Crichton off
Franco did kill his wife and kid and
that's that was also for shattered
foreshadowed like in a phone
conversation that earlier on you know
everything in this is foreshadowed like
everything that happened in the
beginning like it comes back later on so
it's very very well put together if
you're like paying attention because
everything is called back like later
every conversation they had every image
every everything so so what Franco does
essentially it's like he did kill his
wife and kid but he also took credit for
the three women in the apartment that
Francesco killed now here's where it
gets kind of weird because then
Francesco goes to visit like Franco
tries to kill himself I think by
drinking iodine and so he's like in a
coma and Francesco goes to visit him in
the hospital Franco doesn't remember him
which was very tenant like I thought
that scene was very tenant like but then
while that whole thing was going on
because Franco's like I don't know you I
don't know you and all this even though
they were like best friends before and
then like doctors and nurses start
coming in and Francesco starts shooting
him like and
middle of the [ __ ] hospital and then
when he leaves the cop comes up and he's
like there's a madman up there on the
fourth floor like shooting people and
you know it he's like oh you have a gun
good it's like you know he's like I did
it I did it but no one's listening so I
feel like I have seen a theory that
Francesco and Franco are actually the
same person like Francesco was like
Franco's kid like running around loose
or some [ __ ] like that which I guess you
could kind of read it that way too but
see so as the thing goes on like when
they get to the very end what ends up
happening is that Francesco and Nagi
decide that they're going to leave
buffle aura and they're gonna go out and
see the bigger world now again this is a
callback because he was telling somebody
on the phone I think he was talking to
Franco on the phone earlier in the movie
where he said something about like I
don't even know what the rest of the
world looks like I don't even know if it
exists anymore and all this other kind
of stuff because like I said there's a
very life and death like purgatory all
kind of thing going on so him and Nagi
get in the car and they drive you know
through the streets of Buffalo and then
they go through this tunnel and when
they come out of the tunnel there's a
steep drop-off and then there's nothing
there's just without ins there's like a
cliff and those like there's nothing
more Road goes over a cliff and he just
basically says oh is just as I suspected
the rest of the world doesn't exist yeah
so they're they're not in a normal
dimension yeah I think they're in an
imaginary theoretical dimension or it's
in someone else's head because they do
because then they're like both sitting
there and then it starts to snow which
is a reference back to it's not only a
reference to [ __ ] rosebud Citizen
Kane but it's also a reference to the
very first shot of the film which was a
snow globe with two guys standing on it
shows a snow globe with the two guys
with them standing on the edge of it so
they're in a snow globe yeah so it's
almost kind of like they like there
isn't a world outside of Buffalo you
know the way I took it is that the whole
thing was just like a was a learning
experience it was like a hypothetical
situation yeah they're supposed to learn
from that it was inside a snow globe for
you to see yeah that's why I so I don't
think it really happened yeah I think it
was like it's just an example yeah I
think it definitely had that I think
another thing too was that there was a
role reversal because um you know like I
said Nagi who was kind of
mentally challenged quote-unquote
through the whole thing and can only say
one word which was nah that's all he
could say but he said it like in
different inflections like depending on
what he meant and so at the very end of
the movie when you know he's they're
both just sitting there by the cliff and
then they're thinking about going back
to Buffalo aura and Nagi turns around
and says in a perfectly normal voice
he's like I'd like to go back home right
now yeah and then Francesco says yeah at
him so there's like a role reversal to
end and it was also kind of a thing to
where he realized that Nagi was actually
his best friend and yeah all this other
kind stuff but they might have been the
same being different at different
aspects of the same I think yeah and I
think there was something with the to do
with Franco as well like his other
living friend who took credit for his
murders and like he liked Francesca
couldn't get arrested
no super-ego in the it was something
like that
this was definitely some kind of like
hypothetical was a hypothetical symbolic
sort of situation but like I said I know
it sounds like when you say it like that
sounds like kind of pretentious or wacky
or so that god but it's not like that at
all it's still like a fun zombie movie
they're still like zombie gore I mean
they're still like great scenes like the
the dude with the [ __ ] in the
motorcycle accident like Claudio and he
gets like buried and with his motorcycle
just like in psycho mania and he busts
out like [ __ ] meatloaf and then this
other girl is like there she has come to
the she had heard that the that people
were resurrecting like at the cemetery
so she sneaks back in there because she
wants to see him again to find out if he
loves her more than Valentina and all
this other stuff and she comes back
there and he she gets on the motorcycle
this dead dude he's like [ __ ] helmets
all [ __ ] up and his eyes got was the
glass sticking out and [ __ ] and it's
like said you know so Francesco finds
them and he's eating her and then he
goes to shoot the zombie and she's like
don't shoot he's only eating me mind
your business I'll be eaten by whomever
I please she says so it's like the humor
in this is very like deadpan and I don't
know there's just something really
really funny this reminds me a little
bit of that movie of the loved ones that
black and white movie it has kind of
like a similar sense of humor to I get
that one oh why it's very good we should
do like a thing of that expensive on
blu-ray and DVD it's hard to find but
it's a loved one was great Jonathan
winters
yeah but this has like a similar like
very like a morbid yeah
deadpan humor to it you know and like I
said it looks gorgeous is very very very
gothic and not like in a Tim Burton any
kind of way it's not of more like a
classical gothic and it's weird because
the cemeteries that they use these were
real cemeteries they used a different
one for a night and day I guess just
because of the way the lights worked out
or whatever but it looks incredible like
it looks really [ __ ] is that because
apparently they didn't even have to do
much that decorate it looks like I got
the Kitaen horror movies just yeah but
it's just yeah and if you're it's like I
said it's hard to get you can watch it
free on YouTube at least until like the
copyright I'd better hurry if somebody
take it down say if you want to see it
go see it it's expensive and hard to
find on yeah like I said I don't even
think it's on blu-ray it's on DVD but
that came out in 2006 and there's not
really that much extra [ __ ] on it that I
remember I think there was just like one
featurette that was like half an hour
and a trailer and that was it there was
like no director commentary or anything
so this is a movie that really if you're
into Italian or if you're just into like
really weird like gothic black comedy
type of horror movies I think you would
really dig this and I think it needs to
get seen more and it's kind of a shame
that it doesn't because I mean I can see
how like why cuz it's kind of strange
and I think a lot of people will watch
it and be like the end be like what the
[ __ ] but there is kind of like if you
watch it more than once you do pick up
various symbolic things to tell you know
it's just an Italian horror movie it's
got a 70s kind of vibe to it yeah but
it's a modern production you'll like it
just you know you can see for free on
and also I want to mention too that um
you know if you're into like kind of
looking into a lot of the symbolism and
like [ __ ] like that because you know it
references well it references a lot of
paintings and stuff like that too but
there was this one guy who his name is
douglas kisi from california polytechnic
i guess he was a film student or
something and he actually wrote like a
twenty page paper on this like i'm
particularly the psychosexual kind of
like the relationship between him and
her and all this other kind of stuff
called intertwining of death and desire
in Micheli swabbies della morte dell
amore and you can read it for free
online it's actually really interesting
i read it so i would recommend that if
you just you know when at what i just
said just google that and you'll find it
there's one that's that you have to pay
to download but somebody
put it up for free - it's like a PDF but
it kind of goes into a lot about this
movie and there's like a lot to kind of
you know pick apart about this movie and
you can kind of have a bunch of
different theories about it but yeah
definitely go watch it on YouTube if
it's still there check it out it's
really really good it's really weird if
you love odd cinema and Italian cinema
but you will love it